so it's my belief if you look at belfort
you look at bradley you look at grant
cardone some of the big sales trainers
that are out there almost all of them
invariably have the same story which was
i started selling and was the best guy
on the team by a [ __ ] mile and then i
tried to figure out what i was doing and
so i do think
that some people naturally based on
their childhood their upbringings their
whatever or just have a higher
proclivity for selling it carries over
into how you recruit for selling too
because we've built a lot of sales teams
and i actually have a very short
allowing for people to fail at sales
cycle probably much shorter than most
people and it's just because i've never
had a killer sales person who didn't do
pretty well the first week and so for me
we you know we turn through this quickly
but as a result of that the team is just
killers and they know that so i like
this quote from from grant cardone he
says you know my sales team's a
dangerous place to work